[MUSIC PLAYING]
Maps are awesome because
they show us where to go.
But how are your users getting
to their chosen destination?
I'm Ankur Kotwal, and
I'm going to uncover
the Maps APIs that can make
this an amazing user experience.
Are you using the
Directions API?
It's a big revelation, so let
me tell you more about it.
The Directions API
web service provides
step-by-step
directions from point A
to point B. Being a web service,
it's protected by an API key
and thus should not be consumed
directly in your mobile app.
Proxy it via your
server, as shown here.
The Directions API can give you
walking, cycling, and driving
directions, as you'd
expect, but it can also
give great public
transport directions.
When guiding users
to a destination,
it's best to show them
the path on a map.
Polylines are a great
way to show the path,
but rather than have
the polyline appear,
it's nicer to
animate it in place.
In this demo, we can
see the path grow,
providing a clear distinction
about the direction of travel.
So now we're showing users where
to go and how to get there,
but once they're at
their destination,
our app's work is not done.
I really wish more
apps would show me
what my destination looks
like, because often,
it's not obvious which
shop I need to get to.
In effect, users can be
left feeling lost after they
get to their destination.
Thankfully, there's
a Maps API for that.
Street View is a
great way to visualize
the user's destination,
or any address, really.
Adding Street View adds a
real-world visual element
to your app and provides
meaningful context for users.
Users will generally
expect that they
can interact with
the Street View,
since they're likely to pan
and scan around the location,
so be sure to leave
interactivity in place.
You can add a Street View
panorama into your app
by including it in your layout.
Give it an initial
location like so.
It's important to
maintain user context.
And thus, the introduction
of a Street View
should not replace
the map but instead
slide in to occupy the
part of the screen like so.
Here, we're overlaying
a Street View on the map
and sliding it in as per the
material design guidelines.
The only change we
need to make to our map
is to adjust the
padding values such
that the attributions and
Google logo stay visible
and your app remains compliant
with the terms of service.
You can reverse the
animation if you
need to hide the Street View.
So with guided directions
and the addition
of Street View in
your apps, users
are given a visual
representation
of their destination.
They're no longer lost
on their way there.
And now, they're no longer
lost when they get there.
To learn more about
adding Street View,
check out the docs
and sample code here.
I'm Ankur Kotwal, and I
never want to be lost again.
[MUSIC PLAYING]